هنا المنطقه
مدمره هنا نجح المواطنون بالامس وقبل امس
بانتشال عده شهداء من هذه المنطقه
وتشجيعهم الى
مثواهم
الاخير حجم دمار كبير لا
يوصف نحن الان نقترب من
شارع
الفويه وسنذهب الى شارع مدارس وكاله الغوت
هنا
نشاهد حجم الرصاص في هذه المدرسه واعتاد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما نشاهد
هنا هنا نشاهد العتاد الاسرائيلي الذي
احترمه المواطنون بعض من الصناديق الرصاص
وحجم الرصاص الكبير في هذه المدرسه كما
ذكرنا الاحتلال كان يتخذ هذه المدرسه مقرا
عسكريا
له شناه فش عين بني ادم تتوقعوا اباده
كامله لا في مدارس لا تعليم ولا تصلح لشيء
بعد
هيك حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله
ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل الان نحن في داخل مدارس وكاله
الغوت في بلوك 12 وهنا نشاهد ايضا خط
الاحتلال عبارات باللغه العبريه على جدران
هذه المدرسه زي ما انت شايف ما مش مخليين
ولا دار ولا دوار ولا مدرسه ولا مسجد ولا
مخليين حاجه يعني اقسم بالله ضرد على بدن
يعني وين ما كان وين ما كانان ضمار وين
مكان دمار وين مكان هنا
ايضا تجريف كبير لطائرات دبابات الاحتلال
في داخل مدرسه البريج
الاعداديه سنشاهد حجم الدمار داخل
هذه
[تصفيق]
المدرسه
[موسيقى]
دمار واسع جدا
حقيقه كما
نشاهد هنا مسجد البريج الكبير الذي يعد
احد اقدم المساجد في مخيم البريج وهو
المسجد الاول الذي بني في عام
[موسيقى]